Today, we're going to talk about a
staple of the contract law. Canon,
the famous chestnut of
Hadley vs Baxendale.
In some respects, this may be the
case furthest removed from us today.
It was decided more than a century
and a half ago in 1854 in England.
Uh,
but the Hadley rule concerning recovery
for foreseeable consequential damages is
with us today and largely unchanged form.
Yeah.
The brothers of Joseph and Jonah Hadley
owned the city flour mills in cloud
Chester,
England.
The crank shaft in the steam engine
used to power the mill broke holding the
mills operation.
The Hadley's needed to get the broken
crank shaft to the steam engines
manufacturer in Greenwich so that the
manufacturer could provide a replacement.
The Hadley send an employee to
the defendant's offices, uh,
of Pickford and sons to have
them transport the crank
shaft to the manufacturer.
The Hadley employee and Pickford and sons
agreed that the delivery would be made
the following day for a cost of
two pounds and four shillings.
The employee did not explain that the
mill was inoperable due to this broken a
shaft,
but then because of some neglect unquote,
the delivery was delayed and so the
mill couldn't run for several more days.
The plaintiff sued arguing contractual
breach and seeking damages,
not only for the amount they
paid for the shipping service,
but also for their lost profits
of having the mill closed.
The judge quote left the
case generally to the jury,
which awarded a verdict of
25 pounds damages taking
into account the plaintiff's
lost profits for the days
the mill couldn't run.
Okay.
Does the some neglect on the part of
the company that the opinion discusses
matter in this action?
Not really.
There's a strict liability for
breach of contractual promises. Uh,
whether it was intentional,
whether it was negligent,
even if it was not negligent. If you
don't perform, you're promises, uh,
you have to compensate.
The other side.
The Hadley Court awarded a new trial
on the ground that the judge hadn't
properly instructed the jury,
barren Adelson and
influential judge agreed.
He announced the rule that parties to
contract are only liable for damages that
were foreseeable at the
time of contract formation.
The court found that damages for breach
of contract should be such as may fairly
and reasonably be considered either
arising naturally from breach of contract
itself or such as may reasonably be
supposed to have been in the contemplation
of both parties at the time they made the
contract as the probable result of the
breach of it.
Did this necessarily mean that the
jury's verdict of 25 pound damages was
incorrect?
Not Quite.
The court explained that parties could
inform each other of unique circumstances
that could make the damages
of a breach more significant,
more foreseeable then they'd be in
an ordinary case if they did so.
These more significant damages would still
have to be foreseeable if the special
circumstances were communicated by the
plaintiff to the defendant and thus known
to both parties.
The damages resulting from the breach
of such a contract which they would
reasonably contemplate would be the amount
of injury which would ordinarily flow
from a breach of contract under
these special cir circumstances.
So known and communicated.
It's important to understand that the
error the court found was not that the
jury award was necessarily too big.
It was that the judge had
failed to explain to the
jury that it's ward had to be
limited to foreseeable damages.
The court did not rule that a properly
instructed jury could not have returned
the same damage award.
On that note,
let's make clear that we understand
the difference between direct and
consequential damages.
One way to differentiate between these
damages is to distinguish the damages
that are needed to choir substitute
goods or services or their equivalent,
which is we just saw,
uh,
last time might be captured by cost
or performance or dimunition in value
damages.
So we want to distinguish those damages
from the damages flowing from the loss
incurred as a consequence or a result
of the plaintiff not having the promised
goods or services,
which in this case is the plaintiff's
lost profit from not having the mill. Uh,
operable
a rule that says non foreseeable lost
profits like Hadley are nonrecoverable may
seem unfair.
Can you think of any reasons why
courts might impose this limitation?
Well, veterans Adelson's
opinion explained quote,
had the special
circumstance has been known.
The parties might have specialty provided
for breach of contract by special
terms as to the damages in this
case and have this advantage.
It would be very unjust to deprive them.
You see,
if parties are aware of
special circumstances that
will expose them to greater
liability,
they likely will take more care to make
sure they perform and charge more for
their services.
Similarly,
if parties know that courts will
hold them responsible for damages,
they could not foresee,
they will raise their prices generally
to take into account this greater chance
that they're going to be
tagged for high damages.
They'll not be able to tailor their
care to customers who need it the most.
As a result, customers who only
have typical foreseeable damages,
we'll have to pay more to help ensure
customers with atypical damages.
Okay.
Federal Express you, Fedex, uh,
provides that when
shipping packages quote,
unless a higher value is declared and
paid for our liability for each package is
limited to $100,
uh,
for each package exceeding a hundred
dollars in declared value and additional
amounts will be charged unquote.
That's,
that's from the Fedex contract
on every FedEx package.
Why might this be a better policy for
customers than if Fedex did not limit
liability for valuable items over $100?
Well,
it's for exactly the same
reason we've just discussed.
It makes more sense to require those who
might incur substantial consequential
losses if their packages are lost or
damages to be more to insure them than to
have all those who use FedEx services
to foot the bill for others valuable
shipments and it lets FedEx know when
it needs to take special care to get a
package through.
As we noted at the outset,
this was an English case,
not in an American case,
but courts in the United States
typically follow the Hadley rule.
The Supreme Court at the turn of the
century suggested a different path.
Justice Holmes asserted in globe refining
versus Landa cotton oil company that
quote mere notice to a seller of some
interest or probable action of the buyer
is not enough necessarily and as a
matter of law to charge the seller with
special damages on that account.
If he fails to deliver the goods unquote,
the defendants had to have
at least tacitly agreed to
be liable for these extra
losses at issue,
but most courts reject this test.
It is enough that the defendant for saw
or had reason to foresee the plaintiff's
losses that are being claimed.
This is reflected in the restatement
of contracts section three 51 which
provides damages are not
recoverable for loss,
that the party and breach did not have
reason to foresee as a probable result of
the breach when the contract was made.
Loss may be foreseeable as a probable
of a breach because it follows from the
breach in the ordinary course of
events or be as a result of special
circumstances beyond the ordinary course
of events that the party and breach has
reason to know.
So is the handily rule a default
rule or a mandatory rule?
Now it's a default rule.
Parties can contract around it by
giving sufficient notice of special
circumstances.
Parties can also contract out of
the rule in the other direction.
They can explicitly exclude all
liability for consequential damages.
There's usually a a term
excluding liability for
consequential damages and most,
uh,
consumer electronics contracts.
But Rob Gertner and I have categorized
a Hadley vs Baxendale doctrine as an
example of a penalty default or
an information forcing default.
The court's refusal to
award unforeseeable damages,
uh, uh, is a refusal, not because
those damages aren't real,
but the dot Hadley doctrine gives promises
and incentive to reveal information
to the promise sores about what otherwise
would be unusual consequential damages.
One way to think about cases like Hadley
where breach occurred because of some
neglect is through a
torts lens where the law,
among other things should be trying
to induce optimal promissory procop
precaution.
The risk of nonperformance can be
thought of as the probability of
nonperformance.
The probability of breach multiplied
by the loss to the promise. See,
including consequential damages that
will result from nonperformance.
That's the,
the risk can be thought of as
the probability times the loss.
A standard move in law and economics is
to place the risk of loss on the better
risk bear.
A good risk bear will tend
to have information and
control information about the
size of the risk and,
and the control or ability to
take action to change that size.
And here's the structural problem
with regard to contractual risks.
Promissors tend to have better knowledge
and control about the probability of
breach,
but promise sees,
tend to have better knowledge and control
about the size of loss that will occur
that will result if breach occurs.
The shipping company.
Pickford knew more about the probability
that the ship would be delivered and
it's better place to take action to affect
that probability say by strapping on
more horses to the carriage, to to make
sure that the shipment goes through,
even if one of the horses goes lane,
the Hadley's on the other hand knew
more about the size of loss if there,
uh,
if their factory had to close down and
they were better able to control the size
of the loss, say by keeping
spare crank shafts in stock.
So at first glance, it seems difficult
to decide whether the promise or,
or the promise prophecy
is the better risk bearer,
the promise or has better knowledge and
control of one variable p the promise he
has better knowledge and
control of the other variable l.
But the genius of the Hadley rule is
that by using an information forcing
default contract law can tip the scales
and make the promise or the better risk
bear by inducing promises to disclose
the size of their loss to the promise or
the Heather Headley rule makes the
promise or now better place to bear this
loss.
Armed with better information about both
the probability of breach and now also
the size of the preach.
Moreover,
as we could see from the FedEx example,
since promissory are going to respond to
Hadley information by charging a higher
price, uh, when performing
for a high damage primacy,
the Hadley rule even indirectly
gives promises, incentives,
uh,
to exercise their control over the
size of the loss to mitigate damages.
Some Fedex shippers will find it cheaper
to keep extra crank shafts in stock
rather than pay the extra insurance that
will be required if high prospective
damages are disclosed.
We have discussed the influence of the
Hadley rule in the United States and the
policy concerns that underlay it.
We should note another less obvious way.
Hadley proved influential.
Recall where the court in Hadley
placed the error that occurred.
The jury was not at fault for a warning.
Excessive damages.
Rather the judge improperly,
uh,
instructed the jury as
the court explained quote,
we deem it to be expedient and necessary
to state explicitly the rule which the
judge that the next trial
ought in our opinion,
to direct the jury to be governed by
when they estimate the damages unquote
Hadley was decided in an era in which
English courts increasingly reformulated
questions of fact that had been left
previously to the jury's discretion.
Like damages as matters
of law to be judging,
to be decided by judges,
by making a rule that consequential
damages can only be awarded if damages are
foreseeable, the court's dramatically
limited. The jury's power.
This form of jury control became common
in the United States as well as in
England.